[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران التي صدر منها نفي لافت
للوصول للاتفاقا مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بشان تركيب كاميرات جديده
في منشات ايران النوويه
الان الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه التي كشفت
فيها مصادر عن استخدام روسيا لاول مره في
الحرب قنابل شديده التدمير وخارقه
للتحصينات
والى براندومبرغ في المانيا التي قال فيها
المستشار علا عقب لقائه رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ان الصين تعهدت بعدم ارسال اسلحه الى
روسيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد يوم من زياره جروسي وجدل في طهران
بشان التفاهمات مع الوكاله رئيس منظمه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه يقول انه يحق
للوكاله الدوليه تفتيش مراكز التخصيب بناء
على اتفاق محدد ويؤكد ان ملف تقسيم
اليورانيوم بنسبه
84% قد اغلق ونتنياهو يصف تصريحات التي
رفض فيها اي هجوم على منشات نوويه بغير
المناسبه ويتمسك بهدف منع ايران من حيازه
اي سلاح نووي
[موسيقى]
سعيا لتحقيق اول انجاز ميداني كبير في
الحرب منذ سته شهور القوات الروسيه تعمل
على حسب الوضع في بخموت عبر تجديد حصارها
كبار قاده الجيش الروسي يطلعون وزير
الدفاع على الوضع الميداني الحالي
يشدد على دعم خطوط الامداد والقياده
الاوكرانيه تقول انها تتاهب لهجمات
صاروخيه محتمله
على ضوء حمله اعتقالات شملت شخصيات من
القوى المعارضه في تونس
مظاهره لجبهه الخلاص تطالب باطلاق سراح
المعتقلين وتدعو الى اسقاط ما سمته
الانقلاب
والداخليه تقول انها قامت بتامين المظاهره
رغم عدم امتثال الجهه المنظمه لقرار منع
التظاهر
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا نقشنا معكم تداعيات الزلزال
المدمره الذي ضرب مناطق واسعه في جنوب
تركيا وشمال غربي سوريا حيث تجاوز عدد
الضحايا 45 الف قتيل في تركيا ونهز سته
الاف في سوريا لكن اللافته هو تعثر اعمال
الاغاثه والصعوبات الكبيره في التعامل مع
ما سببه هذا الدمار في شمال غربي سوريا
اضافه الى بطء المساعدات وشحها الامر الذي
عرض الهيئات الانسانيه الدوليه لكثير من
الانتقادات والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
الذي يقول لماذا كانت المساعدات الدوليه
دون المامول من اهالي المناطق المتضرره
كيف كانت الاجابات
43% ارجعوا الامر الى صعوبات سببها النظام
السوري
في مقاله عشره بالمئه ان السبب هو الاوضاع
الميدانيه في شمال سوريا بينما قال 47% ان
السبب الحقيقي هو تراجع ملف سوريه على
الاجنده الدوليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا كالعاده على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
بظل توتر مع دول الجوار وواشنطن الصين
تعزز نفقاتها العسكريه للعام الجاري
ورئيس الوزراء الماليزي يحذر في مقابله مع
الجزيره من تداعيات الصراع بين الولايات
المتحده والصين
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي ان المحدد الاساسيه لعمل
ايران في برنامجها النووي هو قانون
الاجراءات الاستراتيجيه التي سنها
البرلمان الايراني واتفاقيات الضمانات
الشامله ومعاهده الحد من الانتشار النووي
واضاف ان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
تشرف على برنامج ايران النووي في اطار
اتفاقيه الضمانات الشامله ومعاهده الحد من
الانتشار النووي مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
ملاحظات طهران واكد ان بلاده لن تنفذ
قانونا لا تلتزم بقيه الاطراف ببنوده وان
ملف جزئيات اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 84%
قد اغلق وان الاساس الذي تم الاتفاق عليه
هو قياس مقدار المخزون الذي يتم انتاجه من
اليورانيوم موضحا انه بناء على قوانين
الوكاله فمن حق ها تفتيش مراكز تخسيب
اليورانيوم وان ذلك يتم وفق اتفاق وقوانين
محدده
جاء هذا الكلام بعد ساعات من نفي المتحدث
باسم هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه بهروز
كما لاوندي ان تكون طهران والوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اتفقت على تركيب
كاميرات مراقبه جديده في المنشات النوويه
[موسيقى]
بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
لم تحل زياره رافايل جروسي لطاهران
المسائل العالقه فقد نفت هيئه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه وجود تفاهم مع الوكاله
الدوليه بشان قضايا عده اولها تركيب
كاميرات مراقبه جديده في المنشات النوويه
نفت الهيئه ذلك وقالت ان الموضوع لم يطرح
اطلاقا خلال الزياره النفي الايراني شمل
الحديث عن زياده زيارات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه لمواقع ثلاثه تصفها بغير
المعلنه وتزعم العثور فيها على اثار
يورانيوم اما المساله الثالثه فتخص منشاه
فوردو وتقول هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
ان زياده عمليات التفتيش في المشاه بنسبه
50% وفقا لاعداد مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه جزء من اتفاقيات الضمانات
معنى من فيينا لورا ركود كبيره المستشارين
القانونيين السابقه بالوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ومن طهران محمد مهدي شريعه
مداري الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه السابق ونبدا
بالسيده لورا ريكورد
كيف فهمتي هذا
التضارب بين الوكاله وايران وهذه البيانات
المتلاحقه التوضيحيه من طهران
اعتقد من المهم جدا ان البيان المشترك
الذي تم كتابته من قبل الرئيس
والمدير غراسي قد يكون هنالك بعض سوء
الفهم على ما تم التوافق عليه ولما لم يتم
التوافق عليه لكن ما هو مهم هو ما حصلنا
عليه من البيان المشترك الذي يتحدث بشكل
خاص عن تطوراني مهمان اولهما حول مساله
قضيه الضمانات التي وافقت فيها ايران على
توفير المعلومات وامكانيه الوصول ايضا
القضيه الثانيه تتعلق بمساله التحقق
والاليه بمحاوله
اعاده تاسيس ربما لنقطه يتم استخدامه اذا
ما تم الاخذ بنظر الاعتبار مساله احياء
الملف الاتفاق النووي القضيه الثالثه
المتعلقه
وايجاد
بروتوكولات لمساله
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 84 بالمئه
والاخذي بالنظر الاعتبار النسب العاليه
لفوردو سيكون من الطبيعي تنفيذ مساله
تطبيق روتينات اضافيه خاصه بعمليات
التحقيق هناك والتفتيش ولكن بالنسبه
لطهران سيد محمد مهدد الشريعه مداري
لماذا اضطرت ايران لتوضيح مسائل عديده في
حين يفترض بان هذه المساله المسائل كانت
واضحه مع الوكاله
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفتك ولمشاهدي قناه الجزيره نعم البيان
المشترك الذي صدر كان واضحا لكن كانت هناك
بعض
التساؤلات حول ما اذا كان هذا البيان لا
يتفق مع القانون الصادر عن مجلس الشورى
الاسلامي والذي يحدد
عمليات التفتيش لذلك اقتضاء التوضيح لا
سيما بنسبه لموضوع
اضافه الكاميرات من قبل الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بمعنى
فقط
مقاطعه بسيطه يعني بمعنى هذه مسائل تم
الاتفاق حولها ولكن عندما عاد المسؤولون
الايرانيون الى المراجع الدستوريه اتضح
انها لا تتلاء معها
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا ليس كذلك لم يتم
الاتفاق على زياده عدد الكاميرات مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لكن
الايضاح الذي صدر هو يعني كان ايضاحا لما
حصل في المفاوضات بين الطرف الايراني
والسيد جلوسي
والمدير العامري الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ليس الا لم يتم الاتفاق على زياده
عدد الكاميرات لذلك اقتضاء التوضيح
نقطه ان
التخصيب بنسبه تتجاوز 80% قد اغلق هل هذا
التطمين يمكن الركن اليه
سيد شريعه مداري
لاحظ
ايران ايران له يعني لها القدره على تخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه اكبر من حتى من 80 او
84% وهذا ما اعلنته سابقا لكن اعلنت انها
تتوقف عند نسبه الستين بالمئه
بعض
الذرات او الجزيئات التي تم العثور عليها
مؤخرا وهي بسيطه جدا يعني لا ترتقي الى
مستوى ان تكون نسبه اليورانيوم قد وصلت
الى هذه النسبه وانما هذا يحصل تقنيا وبعد
التوضيحات التي قدمتها ايران للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كانت هذه التوضيحات
تقنيا مقبوله لدى الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه لذلك تم اغلاق هذا
الملف او هذا الموضوع اليوم لا يوجد هناك
مشكله في موضوع نسبه التقسيط نسبه التقسيط
هي 60% كما اعلنت ايران ذلك مسبقا هل يمكن
سيده ركود هل يمكن لهذه
الاشارات
الايرانيه ان تطمئن
القليقين من برنامج ايران النووي في الغرب
اذا ما فهمت سؤالك بشكل جيد فيما يتعلق
بالجزيئات التي التي بنسبه 84% التي تم
ايجادها في فوردو فان التفسير الايراني
انها كانت جزءا من عمليات تشغيل اجهزه
الطرد المركزيه المشكله هي انه كان هنالك
نشاطات مستمره في فوردو كان يجب الاعلان
عنها
واعلام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اعرف انه كان هنالك عمليات تحقق لهذه
القضايا وهذا نتيجه
لمستوياتي التخصيب لاكثر من 60% والطريقه
التي ترتبط بها اجهزه الطرد المركزي سيكون
هنالك ربما زياده في
مساله عمليات التفتيش حول الضمانات ليس
بغرض منع ايران من الذهاب الى مستويات
اعلى لكن من اجل التحقق من ان ايران تقوم
بالتخصيب الى مستويات تعهدت بها وليس الى
مستويات اعلى ولكن هذا الاخذ هو الرد سيده
ركود بين ايران وبين الوكاله لتوضيح بعض
المسائل هل يمكن ان يربك
الثقه بين الجانبين
اعتقد
ان من المهم جدا ان الطرفان الطرفين
اجتمعا وتحدث مع بعضهما البعض من اجل
تخفيف التوتر في هذه العلاقه يبدو وكان
كلا من ايران والوكاله ملتزمان بشكل كبير
في ايجادي حلول للقضايا الثلاثه العالقه
فيما يتعلق بالمواقع الثلاثه التي تم
التحدث عنها
يجب ان ننتظر ونرى هذا الامر لكن علينا ان
نتذكر شيء كان هنالك الكثير من التفاصيل
التي تم
انهائها في تلك النقاشات كانت هذه نقاشات
سياسيه ذات مستوى عالي الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ايضا
ستجتمع مع ايضا مع نظرائها في ايران في
الوكاله الذريه الايرانيه من اجل التحقق
من هذه التفاصيل علينا ان ننتظر ونرى ما
هي هذه التفاصيل وكيف سيتم ايجاد حلول لها
ونحن ننتظر سيد شريعه مداري ما التوقعات
الايرانيه من اجتماع مجلس المحافظين في ظل
كل ما سبق
انا اتصور ان مبادره السيد جالوسي لزياره
ايران والمفاوضات التي جرتها البيان
المشترك الذي كان متميزا يعني بالنسبه
للمراحل السابقه والتفاؤل لدى الطرفين
اتصور انه اذا تم التعامل مع هذا الملف
وفق الاسس التقنيه والقانونيه
سيكون البيان للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بيانا يعني يؤكد الحقائق التي تم
مشاهدتها والاتفاق عليها اذا طبعا استمرت
عمليه تسييس هذا الملف وانا لا اظن ذلك
الى حد كبير طبعا ستكون هناك مشكله سنعود
الى الوراء بعد هذا الاتفاق الذي او او
التفاهم الذي حصل اثر المفاوضات الاخيره
شكرا جزيلا لكما محمد مهدي شريعه مداري من
طهران
وفي اسرائيل انتقد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو تصريحات مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايلو روسيا التي قال
فيها ان تنفيذه هجوما على منشات نوويه غير
قانونيه وقال نتنياهو شخص جدير بالاحترام
لكنه ادلى بتصريحات غير مناسبه مضيفا في
مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه ان
اسرائيل ستواصل الدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه
من يدعو لابادتها والاعداد لذبح مواطنيها
وفق تعبيره قائلا ان اسرائيل تواصل العمل
لمواجهه ايران من خلال مباحثات واعمالا
تجريها على مدار الساعه
قال في طهران ان هجوما اسرائيليا على
منشات نوويه ايرانيه هو غير قانوني
ادلى بتصريحات غير مناسبه خارج اي قانون
هل مسموح لايران التي تدعو بشكل علني
لابادتنا وتدعو لذبحنا هل نمنعه من الدفاع
عن انفسنا واضح انه يسمح لنا الدفاع عن
انفسنا ونحن نفعل ذلك من خلال المباحثات
والافعال على مدار الساعه ولا يمكنني
الخوض في التفاصيل اقول ذلك لانه لا شيء
في العالم سيثنينا عن حمايه دولتنا ومنع
الظالمين من القضاء على دوله اليهود
[موسيقى]
جيش الاوكراني حدوث اي انسحاب جماعي لقوته
من مدينه بمنطقه دوناتس شرقيه اوكرانيا
وقال المتحدث باسم المجموعه الشرقيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه
لا يزال يسيطر على مدينه بخموت مضيفا انا
القتال يدور بشكل اساسي في ضواحي المدينه
من جهه اخرى يواصل وزير الدفاع الروسيه
جولته على جبهات دوناتسك والتقى عددا من
قاده الوحدات المقاتله الروسيه المتمركزه
فيما تسميه موسكو منطقه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه باوكرانيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان شويغو استمع الى تقارير من
القاده بشان الاوضاع على الارض واول
اهتماما خاصا لتهيئه الظروف اللازمه للنشر
الامن للجنود وتنظيم الدعم الشامل للقوات
وعمل الوحدات الطبيه ووحدات الدعم الخلفيه
تنافس ام تكامل ام تبادل للادوار العلاقه
المعقده بين الجيش الروسي ومليشيا فاجنر
في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تفرضها ظروف
الحرب وطموحات شخصيه تحولت الى خلافات لها
تاثير على مسار المعركه لكن على الارض من
يفعل ماذا وكيف ولماذا
على الجبهات الاوكرانيه الجيش الروسي لا
يقاتل وحده بل الى جانبه قوات غير نظاميه
ابرزها ميليشيا فاجنر
توزيع الجبهات بين القوات النظاميه وتلك
التي تعتمد حرب عصابات انعكس في خلافات
على مستوى قياداتها خصوصا بين وزير الدفاع
ورئيس مجموعه فاجنر فكيف تتقاسم القوات
المقاتله الجبهات
تقدر اجهزه استخبارات غربيه عدد عناصر
مجموعه فاجنر العامله في اوكرانيا بخمسين
الف مقاتل كان هذا العدد في بدايه الحرب
لا يتجاوز 10,000 عنصر هم جنود وضباط
سابقون ومقاتلون مخضرمون
لكن الظروف المعركه على الارض وبعد ان
بدات كفتها تميل لصالح كييف دفعت مؤسسه
المجموعه
كما تقول التقارير الغربيه الى تجنيد
عشرات الالاف من السجون الروسيه بصفقه
بسيطه الحريه في مقابل القتال سته اشهر
على الجبهه وفي الوقت الذي واجه فيه الجيش
الروسي عثرات في حربه على اوكرانيا كانت
قوه فادنر اكثر نجاعه رغم قله عدد افرادها
ويعود هذا حسب خبراء الى اعتناق الجيش
الروسي العقيده القتاليه الشرقيه
التقليديه التي تعتمد على فتح جبهات واسعه
وتكثيف العمليات القتاليه والعمل بمنطق
الموجات البشريه لكن هذه الاستراتيجيه لم
تكلل بالنجاح بدليل الفاتوره البشريه
الكبيره في صفوف القتلى من الجيش الروسي
التي يقدرها حلف شمال الاطلسي باكثر من
200 الف قتيل بالاضافه الى تراجع الجيش
الروسي وانتكاساته في كل من
فيما تعتمد مجموعه
اهداف محدده وتركيز المجهود العسكري عليها
كما حدث في سوليدار ويحدث الان في بخمت
وقبلها
وتعمد المجموعه ومقاتلها الى قطع طرق
الامداد والمواصلات والقصف المركز
والاستعانه بالحركه السريعه لمقاتلها يضاف
الى هذا عامل مهم وهو تحفز مقاتليها
واندفاعهم للقتال
معنى من نيويورك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
والاستراتيجي سنكون في البدايه مع السيد
ساك اهلا وسهلا بك هل من توضيح لحقيقه
الموقف في باك موت الان
مساء الخير ان الموقف في باخموت متوتر
وهنالك قتال ديناميكي متغير وهو مستمر
لاكثر من سته اشهر الان وبصراحه اعتقد ان
العالم الان يضحك على روسيا لان روسيا
كانت تقول لاسابيع واشهر انها ستسيطر ضخمه
يوم غد ان ما هذا هذا الامر ادى الى
الاضرار بالجيش الروسي بشكل كبير والجيش
الاوكراني يستمر بالدفاع عن باخ موت على
الرغم من اننا لا نستخدم
التكتيكات التي باستطاعتي جنودنا ان
يستخدمها بمعنى كما قال رئيسنا في السابق
اننا سنستمر
بالدفاع عن باخمات حتى اخر رمق
ومقاربتنا واضحه اننا نحاول ان من خسائر
عدونا خلال سته اشهر الماضيه فان الجيش
الروسي خسر الالاف من جنوده بمحاولته
للسيطره على باخماد اذا سنستمر بالدفاع عن
المدينه كلما استطعنا ومهما طال الوقت
لكننا نحاول
لكننا ايضا لدينا احترام ايضا وتفكير
باهميه حياتي جنودنا وخطوطنا الدفاعيه هل
هل تؤكدون لنا مره اخرى النفي الاوكراني
لاي انسحاب اوكراني حصل من من بخ موت
لكم ان القتال مستمر وان الموقف الموقف
الانساني في باخموت صعب للغايه لانه حاليا
هنالك اكثر من اربعه الاف مدني ما يزالون
عالقين في باخمه وبينهم اطفال وبالتالي من
الصعب جدا اجلائهم بسبب القتال
المستمر وبسبب نيران المدفعيه التي لا
تتوقف بالتالي كما ذكرت اننا سنستمر
بالدفاع عن باخموت كلما استطعنا ذلك
بالنسبه لتصريحات الرئيس
زيلينسكي يقول
المعركه في شرق دومباس موجعه وصعبه هل من
توضيح اكثر
في اي معركه نخوضها الان اي معركه هي صعبه
من الصعب من الصعب لنا من الراقبه الروس
وهم يدمرون مدننا اذا ما اذا ما شاهدنا
فيديوهات وصور من ضخمه ليس باستطاعتنا ان
نرى اي بنايه مما تزال سليمه الروس قاموا
بسرقه اطفالنا هم يقتلون شعبنا هذا امر
صعب للغايه ومؤلم طالما تتحدث عن الروس
الروس استعملوا مؤخرا صواريخ يوبي اي بي
1500 ولها قدره تدميريه كبيره بما في ذلك
للتحصينات
كيف ستواجهون هذا الوضع
نحن نتحدث الى شركائنا فيما يتعلق بتحسين
دفاعاتنا الجويه وايضا نتحدث الى شركائنا
نطلب منهم بالتزويدنا من الجيل الرابع من
المقاتلات الاف سته عشر
لانه هنالك انواع من الاهداف لا يمكن
تحقيقها في مساله الطيران بالتالي نحتاج
الى الحصول على تلك الطائرات المقاتله
بسرعه
السؤال الاخير يتعلق بتصريح رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بان
الربيع المقبل سيشهد معركه اخيره وحاسمه
مع الروس ماذا تتوقعون
سنقوم بكل شيء ممكن بكل ما بوسعنا وهذا ما
نقوم به نحن نهيئ له هجمتنا المضاده لان
هدفنا هو انه حرر الاراضي الاوكرانيه نحن
لا نريد لهذه الحرب ان تستمر وان تكون
حربا مطوله اذا عندما نكون مهيئين لشن
هجمتنا الموضات وموسى عاداتي حلفائنا من
الغرب وبالدعم العسكري الذين تلقاه منهم
نحن نامل اننا سنكون قادرين على انهاء هذه
الحرب هذه هذا العام 2023 سيكون عام النصر
بالنسبه لنا شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك نرحب من
جديد بضيفنا من موسكو بابا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي واسالك في
البدايه عن الروايه الروسيه لما يجري في
باك موت في ضوء النفي
الاوكراني على ان هناك انسحابا من هذه
المدينه
يبدو لي وكان القوات الروسيه هي على حافه
السيطره على مدينه باخموت المحاصره
بعد
حصار استمر لمده طويله
اذا ما تمكن الروس من السيطره على هذه
المدينه سيكون هذا الامر
نصرا معنويا كبيرا ودعما للروح المعنويه
للقوات الروسيه وللكرملين ايضا الذي يريد
ان يظهر هذا الامر في روسيا على انه نصر
حاسب قد لا يكون هو نصر حاسم حقا لكن مع
ذلك بالتاكيد سيكون
انجازا مهما للقوات الروسيه واعتقد ان هذا
ما سيحصل في نهايه المطاف وهذا وهم
سيطردون الاوكرانيين خارج ولكن الان
الاكيد ان القتال هو في ضواحي المدينه كما
تذكر التقارير
نعم هنالك قتال داخل المدينه وفي المناطق
المحيطه بها الروس يستخدمون نيران مدفعيه
مكثفه تكبدوا خسائر كان هنالك خسائر كبدها
الطرفين والضغط على الاوكرانيين للانسحاب
من المدينه هو عال جدا ومن المحتمل انهم
سينسحبوا في نهايه المطاف وستكون كما قلت
هي دفعه معنويه قويه وسيتم تصوير هذا
الامر على انه نصر حاسم للروس على الرغم
من ان من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه او القيمه
الاستراتيجيه لباقمتيه ليست بالكبيره اذا
ما سقطت لا يعني هذا الامر ان الجبهه
الاوكرانيه ستنهار لكن باي حاله من
الاحوال كما ذكرت هو سيكون نصرا للجيش
الروسي هل يمكن اعتبار استعمال الجيش
الروسي لصواريخ مدمره
جدا وخارقه للتحصينات صواريخ اليوبي اي بي
1500 هل يمكن اعتباره مؤشر على ان روسيا
بدات تضيق بسير المعارك وتريد ان تنقل
الامر بشكل نوعي
الروس القوات الجويه استخدمت هذه القوه
استخدمت قنابل ثقيله منزلقه
واستمرت باستخدام هذا الامر لمده طويله
وتم اعلان هذا الامر من قبل القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ايضا هذه
الاسلحه الى حد ما هي نفس الاسلحه
المشابهه للاسلحه الامريكيه هي قنابل
تستهدف
انظمه
وهي قد لا تكون بتلك الدقه التي تمتاز بها
القنابل الامريكيه وايضا مداها اقصر لكنها
اكثر فتكا
وايضا هنالك هامش للخطا يصل الى عشر امتار
لكن
لدينا قنبله
زينتها طن تسقط على التحصينات بالتالي
الروسي يستخدمون الكثير من الاسلحه
الجديده التي
تحدث فرقا في ارض المعركه الاوكرانيون
يستخدمون الاسلحه
من اجل من اجل حث الحثي هم يقولون ان
روسيا يستخدمون هذه الاسلحه لحث الغرب على
تزويدهم بالاسلحه لكن لا اعتقد ان عمليات
التجهيزهم بالمقاتلات الحديثه سيحدث قريبا
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث شهدت العاصمه اليوم مظاهره
نظمتها جبهه الخلاص الوطني المعارضه
للمطالبه باطلاق سراح المعتقلين السياسيين
وقد تمكن المحتجون من اجتياز الحواجز
الامنيه التي وضعتها الشرطه على الطريق
المؤديه او الطرق المؤديه لشارع الحبيب
بورقيبه وقد رفع المتظاهرون شعارات تدعو
الى اسقاط ما يسمونه الانقلاب والاحترام
حقوق الانسان فضلا عن التنديد بالاوضاع
المعيشيه في البلاد وفقدان المواد
الاساسيه وغلاء الاسعار وكان والي العاصمه
قد رفض السماح بتنظيم المظاهره التي تاتي
بعد يوم واحد من مسيره احتجاجيه نظمها
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
وصلت عزيزات امنيه مشدده ومع رفض والي
العاصمه السماحه بالتظاهر جبه الخلاص
الوطني المعارضه في تونس تنظم مسيره
احتجاجيه للتنديد بحمله الاعتقالات التي
استهدفت رموزها
لتصل الى شارع الحبيب بوركيبه حيث تجمع
المحتجون وعائلات نشطاء المعتقلين
للمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم
اولا النقطه الاولى اللي احنا نطالبو انهم
يسيبوا المساجين السياسيين اللي ما عندهم
حتى تهمه
والحاجه الثانيه نحب نقولو احنا المسار
الديمقراطي
ميمتي دخلنا في منعرج خايب برشا مانيش
مسلمين فيه
ياتي هذا التحرك مع زياده حده الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد بين الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ومعارضيه عقب حمله اعتقالات
واسعه
اعتقالات انها تاتي في اطار قضيه التامر
على امن الدوله
[تصفيق]
بينما ترى المعارضه انها تهدف الى التغطيه
على الفشل في معالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
فشل جمله واضحه يغطي في الفشل متاعو في كل
المجالات
بهالمسرحيات الاخراج من اعتقالات رغم
التطبيقي والمنع تواصلوا المعارضه حشدا
انصارها في الشارع بينما تراوح الازمه
سياسيه مكانها رغم دعوات الحوار والتهدئه
التي لم تلقى حتى الان اذان صاغيه بل باتت
لايقافات والمحاكمات فصلا اخر من فصول
المشهد السياسي التونسي المعقد
مع تصاعدي الازمه تصدر جمعيه القضاه
التونسيين بيانا يصف تصريحات الرئيس
المتكرره تجاه القضاه بالخطيره
ويعتبرها تدخل المباشرا في سير التحقيقات
التي يجريها القضاء مع الموقوفين
ونظر التي صعد دائره الاعتقالات التي
استهدفت سياسيين ومحامينا ونقابيين
واعلاميين فان تشكيل جبهه موحده مناهضه
للرئيس بات قريبا وفق ما يرى البعض مشاكل
خلقها قيس سعيد وهي يعني حركت شارع من
جديد ضده ووحدت المعارضه حتى ولو بطريقه
تلقائيه ولا تريد هذا المعرض التوحد طيله
سنه ونصف لكن اليوم هي توحدت يعني بفضل
قيس سعيد
انا اوان محاسبه اعداء الشعب جمله لطالما
كررها الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي دعا مرارا
وتكرارا القضاه التونسيين الى تطبيق
القانون على الجميع وعلى قدم المساواه
وانه لا تراجع عن النصر في معركه التحرير
الوطنيه على حد وصفه سيف الدين معالج
الجزيره تونس
وخلال المظاهره طلب رئيس جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه احمد نجيب الشابي باطلاق سراح
المعتقلين السياسيين وكل التونسيين مما
سماه القبضه الاستبداديه مشددا على التمسك
بالمسار الديمقراطي والشرعيه الدستوريه
ايقافات هي جزء من سياسه عشوائيه لا تطال
فقط
الموقوفين من قياده جبهه الخلاص الوطني
ومن قياده الاحزاب وانما هي ايضا
تطال الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
في الكفاح من اجل تحرير اخواننا
وسنقوم بكل الاعمال التي يقتضيها الدعم
البشري والدعم القانوني
والتحسيس الاعلامي
والوقفات الاحتجاجيه حتى يتحرروا
هذا وقد كانت وزاره الداخليه التونسيه
اصدرت بيانا قالت فيه ان الوحدات الامنيه
تولت اليوم تامين ما سمته تحركا احتجاجيا
في شارع الحبيب بورجيه بالعاصمه واضافت
الداخليه التونسيه انه رغم عدم امتثال
الجهه المنظمه لقرار السلطه الجهويه بعدم
الموافقه فانه جرى تامين المظاهرات وفقا
لمقتضيات الامن والنظام العام وفق تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الصين رفع الميزانيه العسكريه
الجديده لعام 2023 بنسبه 10% مقارنه
بالعام الماضي جاء ذلك خلال افتتاح اعمال
الدوره الرابعه عشر للمؤتمر الوطني لنواب
الشعب بحضور نحو ثلاثه الاف مندوب
[موسيقى]
صفحه جديده من الوحده بين الجيش والحكومه
والشعب هكذا وصف رئيس الوزراء الصيني دعم
بيتشين للتطوير في مجال الدفاع خلال كلمته
بمناسبه انطلاق اجتماعات مجلس نواب الشعب
تم رفع الانفاق الدفاعي لعام 2023 بنحو
عشر في المئه مقارنه بالعام الماضي زياده
طفيفه تؤكد الصين انها لا تشكل تهديدا لاي
دوله اخرى بل تراها ضروريه لتطوير قدراتها
الدفاعيه
يجب تطوير الجيش بتنفيذ السياسه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لتحقيق هدف المئه
عام لجيشنا وذلك بتوحيد وتوسيع الدفاع
الوطني والاصلاحات العسكريه والتركيز على
تطوير التكنولوجيا العسكريه
كما اكد رئيس الوزراء الصيني على اهميه
تكثيف التدريب العسكري واجراء مناورات
تحاكي حروبا حقيقيه الى جانب تطوير الجيش
شدد مجلس نواب الشعب الصيني على تعزيز
التنميه السلميه للعلاقات مع تايوان لكنه
دعا في الوقت ذاته الى ضروره اتخاذ خطوات
حازمه لمعارضه استقلال
يومين فقط ارسلت الصين ما لا يقل عن 50
طائره حربيه الى محيط تايوان بالتزامن مع
صفقه اسلحه امريكيه للجزيره التي تعتبرها
الصين جزءا من اراضيها وغير بعيد عن مضيق
تايوان تتصاعد التوترات بين بيتين وواشنطن
عقب تعزيز الوجود العسكري الامريكي في بحر
جنوب الصين بنحو ست قواعد امريكيه جديده
بموجب اتفاق مع الفلبين
بسياده الوطنيه لذلك تقوم الصين بتطوير
وتحديث اسطولها العسكري يمكن النقاش في كل
شيء باستثناء سيادتنا على اراضينا فهي غير
قابله للتفاوض لذلك تستعد بجين بكل ما
تملك ترصد الصين مليارات الدولارات لتطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتكنولوجيا الطاقه
النوويه وبرامج مراقبه عبر الاقمار
الاصطناعيه والمناطيط وكان الرئيس الصيني
قد اكد على ضروره تعميق التعاون العسكري
مع موسكو ومطره واشنطن تهديدا لامنها
القومي تؤكد بيجين انه تطوير دفاعي مشروع
شيماء
هذا ويربط متابعون للشان الصيني رفع بيجين
انفاقها الدفاعي بما تواجهه من تحديات
يفرضها التصعيد المتزايد مع الولايات
المتحده ويكشف مكان لصحيفه نيويورك
الامريكيه عن تغيير في التوجهات
الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه لواشنطن تجاه بجين
ومن اهم سمات ذلك التغيير وفق الصحيفه
تدريب وحداه عسكريه خاصه على مفاهيم
قتاليه قد يحتاجها يوما ما في حال اندلعت
الحرب مع الصين
زد انفاقك تزداد قوه ومكمل قوه الجيوش في
تحديثها تعلم الصين ان قدرتها الدفاعيه
عامل حاسم في الرضع والمواجهه لا يسعها
هنا تجاهل ما يفرضه التصعيد المستجد بقوه
مع الولايات المتحده من تحديات
تتعاظم تلك التحديات مع ما كشف من تغيير
في توجهات الاستراتيجيات الدفاعيه
الامريكيه تجاه بيجن
ما عدا الامر قاصر على المناوره المعوده
مع الحلفاء في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادي وعلى عتاب الصين انما هي الاهه
لاندلاع حرب هناك بل والفوز بها تلك مهمه
فوج جديد من مشاه البحريه الامريكيه يخوض
تمرينا هو في الاساس نسخه حياه او موت من
لعبه الغميضه انه الاستعداد لاختبار
مفاهيم قتاليه قد يحتاجها البانتاجون يوما
ما في حال اندلعت تلك الحرب
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه التي تكشف
ذلك تقول ان المناورات التي اقيمت بجنوب
ولايه كاليفورنيا لعبت فيها قواعد عسكريه
نائيه دور سلسله من جزر المحيط الهادي
يفترض المخططون العسكريون ان اي معركه
المستقبليه محتمله مع الصين قد تحدث فيما
يشير اليه البنك غالبا باسم سلسله الجزر
الاولى وتشمل اوكينا وتايوان وصولا الى
ماليزيا وكذلك بحر جنوب الصين والجزر
المتنازع عليها في
ليس سرا تدهور العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
بسبب ما تصفه واشنطن بالتحركات العدوانيه
ضد تايوان الى جانب ما تقول انها محاولات
صينيه لترويع حلفاء امريكا في المنطقه
بينهم اليابان لذلك كله يخشى ان اندلاع
حرب كبيره في المحيطين الهندي والهادي
اصبح محتملا الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ذاك ما يراه خبراء
عسكريون لكن المواجهه اذا تمت ستكون مع
جيش صيني قدر تقرير لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه انه يلحق بسرعه
بمصافي القوات الغربيه
بالنسبه
يقتصر هدف جيش التحرير الشعبي كما تسميه
بشكل اساسي على الدفاع عن مطامحه بالسياده
على حدوده لكنها لا تخفي عمله المستميت
لفرض التفوق الاقليمي واعاقه اي تدخلات
خارجيه في المنطقه
انضموا الينا من لندن اليسيو بتلانو استاذ
دراسات الحرب المختص بشؤون اسيا في جماعه
جماعه كينج في لندن اهلا وسهلا بك مجرد
رفع ميزانيه الدفاع الصينيه بنسبه 10% هل
يثير القلق
نعم جزئيا هذا انعكاس لما كان
نوعا من التيار المتصاعد مع الصين لعدد من
السنوات الان وما هو مثير للانتباه بهذا
بهذه الزياده انه يتم في وقت
الاقتصاد يعاني من ازمه وبسبب سياسه
القضاء على جائحه كوفيد وايضا من حيث
استمرار
النمو الاقتصادي الذي تاخر بسبب
فصلي ملايين من الناس لهذا السبب الاعلان
الذي تم قبل ساعات قليله عن هذه الزياده
تم في ظل وضع اقتصادي لا يبعث على
الارتياح هل يجب ان يكون هذا داعيا لعدم
الارتياح نعم هذا يتعلق جزئيا بمحاولاتي
الصين
تحقيق هدفها الخاص بان تكون قوه تمتلك قوه
عسكريه تناسب القرن الحادي والعشرين وايضا
في ظل التوتر مع الولايات المتحده هذا يجب
ان لا ننساه عندما نفكر بهذه المعطيات
جميعا ولكن هل هناك ما يدعو اكثر لعدم
الارتياح عندما نسمع رئيس الوزراء الصيني
يتحدث عن الاستعداد التام للقتال هذا هو
تعبيره
طريقتان لتاويل ذلك في الحقيقه هذا سؤال
وجيههم طرحتموه لانه يدخل في صميمي النظره
الى هذه الامور من جهه اي قوه عسكريه يجب
ان تكون جاهزه ومستعده للدفاع عن بلدها
وانفاذ السياساتها الوطنيه من حيث المؤسسه
العسكريه ام تكون جاهزه وذات كفاءه لهذا
امر طبيعي لكن في السياق الصيني الامر له
مغزى ايضا لان المؤسسه العسكري الصينيه لم
تدخل في عمليات عسكريه كبيره لاكثر لاكثر
من اربعه عقود اذا اعتبارا من القياده
العليا حتى القيادات المتدنيه لا تمتلك
خبره قتاليه حقيقيه اذا بهذا المعنى الامر
يكون بمث تطور طبيعي للمؤسسه العسكريه
الصيني لكن اذا ما لقينا نظره على سلوكي
الصين في الاعوام القليله الماضيه فيما
يتعلق بمضيق تايوان وايضا فيما يتعلق بما
يحدث في بحر الصين الجنوبي يسمح الامر
مقلقا اكثر لانه في الحقيقه يثير تساؤلات
عمات تريد الصين ماذا تقصد من وراء ذلك هل
تريد فقط
العنايه بوضعها الداخلي ام انها تريد ان
تكون اكثر قوه على استعراض قوتها العسكريه
اذا بهذا المنظور علينا ان نسال انفسنا
السؤال هل هم يحاولون خلق مؤسسه عسكريه
ذات كفاءه عاليه وهل هذا من شانه ان يزيد
من حده التوتر المتوتر اصلا حول النظيق
تايوان وفي بحر الصين الجنوبي وبحر صين
الشرقي ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك
الينو استاذ دراسات الحرب المختص في شؤون
اسيا في جامعه
معنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
نتحدث الان عن الاشتباك المسلح في اقليم
كندا ففي وضع متوتر اصلا في الاقليم تزداد
الخشيه من ان يشعل الحادث جوله قتال جديده
بين الجيشين الاذربيجاني والارمني يقع
اقليم كاراباخ المتنازع عليه بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا يقع جنوب غربي اذربيجان وشرق
ارمينيا فيما يسمى منطقه القوقاز الصغرى
وهو يمتد على مساحه
4400 كيلومتر مربع الاقليم الجبلي يوجد
بالكامل الاقليم الجبلي يوجد بالكامل على
بعد نحو 200 وسبعين كيلو مترا عن عاصمتها
باكو وهو معترف به دوليا على انه جزء من
الاراضي الاذربيجانيه يبلغ عدد سكان
كارباخ نحو 140 الف نسمه
95% منهم ارمنيون وقد خضعت التركيبه
السكانيه لتغيرات مستمره عبر العصور
وتعاقب الامبراطوريه تقول القوات الروسيه
التي تتولى حفظ السلام في الاقليم انها
رصدت خلال فبراير شباط الماضي انتهاكات
لوقف اطلاق النار في منطقتي مارتوني وشوشا
ومنذ تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي اوائل
التسعينات القرن الماضي شهد اقليم كاراباخ
حربين بين اذربيجان وارمينيا كانت اخرهما
عام 2020 وانتهت باتفاق رعتهم موسكو
وقد كنت قد اجريت قبل الحصاد مقابله مع
ماثيو بريزا الوسيط الامريكي السابق في
نزاع كرباخ بين ارمينيا ودربيجان وحدثناه
من اسطنبول سالته اولا كيف تابع التوتر
الجديد في كندا
نعم تابعت هذا الامر وقد
توقيته مثير للشكوك لانه خلال اجتماع
الامير في مؤتمر ميونخ الامن كان وزير
الخارجيه بلانكا يبدو وكانه عقد اجتماعا
بدان الرئيس لدى البيجاني والرئيس وزراء
ارمينيا وعلى اثر ذلك الاجتماع فان الرئيس
البربجاني قام بشيء الشيء لم يقم به في
السابق ان يجتمع مع الممثل الارميني
الممثل الارميني لاقليمي قراباغ وهود رفض
دائما القيام بذلك وقال ان
جزء من سكان الارمن هناك هم جزء من
اذربيجان ولا يجب عليه ان يلتقي مع مناسب
يحاولون ان يفصلوا من اذربيجان لكنه في
تلك المناسبه وافق على ان يلتقي به ووافق
على اللق
على ان
المواطنين الروس سابقين من اصول
اذربيجانيه لديهم مكانه مميزه في السلطه
الكهرباء كان عليهم ان يغادروا
ولم
يكن لهم دور للاعبي دور سياسي يلعبونه
بالتالي ما اراه انا وارمينيا كانوا في
طريق مره اخرى نحو ربما مفاوضات
قد تؤدي الى عقد سلاما بين الدولتين
وهنالك الكثير من التاريخ في ارمينيا لا
يريدون تحقيق السلم هنالك اطراف سياسيه
تحاول ان تخرب عمليه السلام وهذا ربما ما
حد صلاه تماما مؤخرا هل لديكم صوره واضحه
عن من بالضبط يريد تخريب هذا المسار
نعم نعم هنالك
ملايين مئات الالاف من الاشخاص في ارمينيا
يشعرون بالاهانه لخساره الحرب الثانيه في
قرابات في نوفمبر عام 2020
وهم ضد رئيس الوزراء
وهم يريدون ان يستمر ويستانف الصراع
والكثير منهم لديهم شعور وطني وقومي قوي
يريدون ان يروا ارمينيا ومنطقه قراباغ
تكون مستقله من تركيا ومن اذربيجان ومن
دول اخرى من اجل استعاده وضعها السابق من
العصور الوسطى ارمينيا الكبرى الكثير من
هؤلاء الاشخاص وهم من
من
قبيله قرباهم اصولهم تاتي منقبه انتقلوا
الى ارمينيا وقادوا البلد بالتالي هذه هذا
يكون هو نمط الذي اتبعوه في السابق ومن
الواضح بالنسبه لي ان كلا رئيس الوزراء
والرئيسه كانوا هم يريدون ان
يحرزوا تقدما في عمليه السلام في
المفاوضات التي تؤدي عليه السلام بين
البلدين قوات حفظ الروسيه هل تعتقد بانها
ما زال لها دور الان في تلك المنطقه
نعم نعم ان قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه تلعب
دورا مهما هم موجودون هناك لكي
يضمنوا ان
القوات الارمينيه ويقوا على يبقوا على وقف
لاطلاق النار الذي تم توقيع عليه بين
الرئيسان وبين برعايه الرئيس بوتين في عام
2020 لكن بوجود قوات ارمينيه ايضا لم
تغادر بالتالي القوات حفظ السلام الروسيه
وهم يلعبوا دورا مهما في ابقاء القوات
الارمينيه بعيدا من القوات الاذربيجانيه
والعكس صحيح لكن غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا قد
اضعف من امكانيات قوات حفظ السلام تلك
وحرمها من تاديه مهامها بشكل كبير لان
الكثير من القوات تم ارسالها الى جبهات
القتالي في اوكرانيا في النهايه ما العمل
لاعاده احياء
مسار التسويه بشكل جدي
اعتقد انما سيكون العنصر مساعد هو وزير
الخارجيه بلنكن وربما
راي وزير رئيس بريال استمروا بالقيام مع
ما كانوا يقومون به الاجتماع مع رئيس
الوزراء الارميني وايضا الرئيس البيجاني
وتقديم التغطيه السياسيه وخاصه من اجل ان
يحرز تقدما في عمليه السينما اعتقد انهم
سيتمكنوا من ربما السيطره على معارضيه
والمعارضين لعمليه السلام ايضا اذا ما
نظرنا الى اخر انتخابات في ارمينيا قبل
سنه ونصف تقريبا فان قوات قوه السياسيه
للبشنيان قد حققت الفوز
ومعارضوه خاسر واذا ما درسوا هنالك الوضع
النفسي للوضع الجديد هم لم يربحوا هذه
الحرب القربا الثانيه يعتقد ان مساله هم
ارادوا ان ياخذ البلد الى مرحله جديده هم
يريدون ان يعيشوا بسلام مع اذربيجان ومع
تركيا ايضا اذا ما كان هنالك سلام بامكان
رفاهيه ان تتحقق هذا الامر سيكون رائعا
للشعب الاميني وايضا لشعوب المنطقه ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد ماتيو برايزا الوسيط
الامريكي السابق في نزاع كارباخ بين
ارمينيا شكرا جزيلا
رئيس الوزراء الماليزي انور ابراهيم ان
الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين امر
مؤسف وان سب وانه سبب مشاكل عديده واضاف
ابراهيم في حديث لبرنامج المقابله ان
ماليزيا بحاجه الى البلدين وان مصلحه
الماليزيين تقتضي البقاء قريبا من الصين
والحفاظ على علاقات وديه مع الولايات
المتحده
بهذا نصل الى نهايه حصاد الليله شكرا على
حسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]